but what is the reality we don't put
anything past the garland justice
department
though we caught this note in as always
the eighth paragraph of the new york
times sweeping article about last
night's filing it included this telling
line little detail eighth paragraph
department officials are not expected to
file charges eminently
if they ever do
at all
joining me now is newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and fox news
contributor newt the trump legal team
responded to the doj a short time ago
contending that they should have known
classified documents would be on the
premises by the very nature of
presidential records what's your
reaction
the
most corrupt
justice department in all of american
history
you have corruption from the attorney
general to the head of the fbi
to senior elements of the fbi
you have collusion from a wide range of
the intelligence community you had i
think it was 50 some intelligent senior
officials who signed a letter last year
that we now know is a total lie
none of whom have recanted
i fully expect the justice department to
indict president trump in a dc court a
district where he got 5.6
of the vote so by 19 to 1 the jury is
likely to be against him
i think this is an all-out effort and
just had
zuckerberg the founder of facebook say
that the fbi asked him to suppress
the hunter biden laptop for the three or
four weeks before the election in 2020
at a time by the way when some 80
percent of americans say if they had
known how corrupt hunter biden and
through him his father were they
probably would have voted against joe
biden so i mean
i have no idea what's going to happen
next i'm a historian by training and i
tell everybody you have to assume that
nothing you know
tells you anything
about how corrupt and how sick this is
going to get because you have fanatics
who represent a secular religion who are
determined to destroy not just trump but
trump's followers
and they could do almost anything we
have no way of knowing what the next six
months or two years are going to carry
as a historian to say the most corrupt
uh
that that says a lot and i want you
talked about how they're characterizing
their opponents we heard how joe biden
you know called trump supporters
semi-fascists well here's the white
house press secretary doubling down
listen
the president thinks that there is an
extremist threat to our democracy
the president has been clear as he can
be on that particular
piece when we talk about a democracy
when we talk about our freedoms
the way that he sees is the mag of
republicans are the most energized part
of the republican party
that extreme this is an extreme threat
to our democracy to our freedom uh to
our rights so political opponents are
the biggest threat to our democracy even
though we're a constitutional republic
you say this is the most corrupt justice
department you've ever seen how
dangerous is our moment
look i think there's a brief period late
in the wilson administration where you
had an attorney general who sort of lost
his mind and they had what was called
the red scare and they locked up a lot
of people including the former
socialist party candidate for president
but it was a very brief period what you
see now
is an institutional commitment that runs
from places like harvard and princeton
and yale to the new york times and the
washington post and the major networks
to the deep state
to the intelligence community the fbi
the justice department and all these
systems are now basically a war with the
american people i mean this is the thing
biden doesn't understand even if you
thought the last election was relatively
fair and i think we learned more and
more about how rigged it was but even if
you thought it was relatively fair 73 or
74 million americans voted for donald
trump to have a present united states
characterize
half of his country in the way that joe
biden does is the greatest act of
aggression by an american president
against his own people that we've ever
seen it's it's truly
an astonishing moment it doesn't fit any
of our prior history and i keep telling
my friends
do not assume anything based on past
precedent because you're now dealing
with people who are terrified i mean if
you're the senior fbi or you're the
white house and you're looking at the
potential of a republican control the
house and senate and you realize all of
your emails all of your meetings
everything that you've been doing could
suddenly become public and your entire
career could be destroyed and you might
end up in jail
i mean you're going to do everything you
can to try to guarantee that the
republicans can't win this fall because
you're terrified of what a republican
congress would be like
and then that feels like a cycle that
doesn't stop as americans needs are
never met uh because they're too busy
imputing their political opponents uh
newt thanks so much for that insight we
appreciate it thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else